[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
we have Stacey oh hi guys she's back
welcome back Stacey he taught me Stacey
D in the house how are you guys mm-hmm
what's your first tattoo oh my god um
actually I talked about this before but
it was this tattoo I got removed from my
hand
we're right here so you could only
really see like a little tiny dot I
don't know I was like I see a big [ __ ]
tear but it's like a super tiny dot do
you see it oh yeah
was it supposed to be median I love that
no it was I think yeah where I held
hands with my best friend in high school
yeah but we got to remote cuz I don't
talk to her anymore but that was my
first recursive with his best Forex best
friend
yes that's what I call it the curse of
the tech oh my sister comes when you get
a matching tattoo with someone that's
like the worst people just grow apart
normally I don't know but I feel like
when you got a tattoo with someone
that's like almost married it's like you
expect it to be forever you knowing you
probably get it like at a happy time in
your life you know and they should
happen it's like 40% so dude high school
friends does everything gotta be the
highest thing on earth
wait so why did you stop can we talk
about why you stopped talking to your
best friend I would just grew apart like
to keep different people and then uh and
then saw like we were we started going
apart a little bit and then my he always
portrayed himself as a certain person
and then so I always thought that was
super dope and then when we both went to
boot camp together and it's like a
really high stress situation like his
true true true colors came out and I'm
like this guy's Wade oh his true colors
was either [ __ ] I was like this guy's
way different than he was and I was
still able to like kind of overlook it
cuz we're just friends so like my heart
score is just not who he says he is but
then he started growing even more apart
after that like you know you're like
[ __ ] he saw my true color yeah maybe I
don't know [ __ ] happen does he watch
your show does he watch it I don't know
mm-hmm oh damn did you feel the sort of
way did you know it really yeah he was
my ex-boyfriend
Oh
remember yeah that's why when I came
into the picture they were already kind
of do cuz he was already doing JK and
[ __ ] yeah are you just saying this to
make it look like you didn't break guy
code
no I already have a new is already
waiter from dune Joe is Joe Joe was on
that broke up a hobby friendship not me
I see okay it was already falling apart
I just came into the picture at the
right time and you [ __ ] came over
there ya know we all had like a it was a
group that even Gio hung out with and
they were they were super tight and I um
I just had a lot of friends so I would
sometimes come and visit it wasn't
special is what you're saying
alright I started to get good really
connect with bar but dad he wasn't my
way into the group I I knew someone else
distance yeah and then we just put yeah
we just started
I think vibing and connecting and
chillin way more what could you guys mad
at the more tight no time we tie yeah
yeah and then afterwards I think I met
you at the same time but then she was
with everyone that when everyone met Gio
that's when I met Gio - yeah but then
yeah it wasn't till like way later cuz
we stopped hanging out with that group
yeah he was like an occasional homie
that would come and be like hey and then
he'd kick it with the whole group it was
also a rapper at that time making beats
all Joe yeah oh yeah can you breathe
that's another time
we play games and stuff but people can't
tell me to do it yeah that's it though
flow and yes it don't need my voice
really you can't tell me to do it there
- you up no can't tell me to do it
that's [ __ ] up that's like going up to
Dane Cook and be like hey man can you be
really unfunny right now and he's like
not doing that that's like you've
slowpoke calls you if I get lift or be
like can you leave something right now
yeah he was at the time ten years ago
girl did you tell your did you like take
a picture of the tattoo we're being
removed and you said yeah that's what I
think all our friends know what no
because so we got it in high school but
then I like started getting it removed
in high school but when I was hanging up
short
I well listen Linda listen so I started
like my first years in high school were
really bad because I was just like
trying to find myself trying to fit in
whatever and so my two years in high
school that's one like I turned my [ __ ]
around I drunk the last two I joined a
Swee like I started getting my [ __ ]
together and so she was part of like the
bad group she wanted to be a chola no it
was like more like the punk rock okay
anyway so I actually never talked to her
again and then yeah literally we were in
the same high school and I would just be
like I don't know you know that's very
normal you know but you know those
friends that like let's say we're all
hanging out and like TIFF tells me like
oh you got like oh my god Stacy like
your hair looks so ugly right now just
so everybody could be like oh yeah your
hair does look really ugly like she was
oh I don't even know what that to like
like in fact they're like if I told you
in private like oh my god I broke her
now like don't tell anyone I feel really
self-conscious and you're like oh my god
you're [ __ ] now it's so
that's what girls can't have tight
friends yeah because I'm [ __ ] leave
wrong no no I mean us but it's hard for
girls to trust each other
I trust girl girls yeah but all girls if
I if I start seeing that kind of
behavior I just like exclude myself you
know but no I couldn't tell her I don't
even know she knows but the other dad
she looked her up on Facebook you guys
and it's just I mean life does its thing
you know all you had knew see a picture
she's fat with kids tell the truth you
don't know I don't think she has kids
all right she's fat that's all that to
me but that's just the Mexican thing
isn't it you're Asian
you're hella fat boy I know that's his
that's his soft spots I had some
American diet
yeah but I don't know she knows that I
removed there I don't ever know she
still has it I was actually thinking um
speaking of tattoos I'm considering
getting my hands like moving into my
hands I know but I also told myself it's
a big commitment right once I have a
million dollars I'm like then I could do
it but I'm like Amelia not even that
much but I write fades faster anyway
over here you know but they were driving
with hands is weird
Hans is weird but has what makes it so
this is weird no sleeves is hot hands
are weird
oh right it's like Nick it's like oh
damn you're about that like a certain
person can fight it I mean can rocket I
think once you have hella money and you
don't really give a [ __ ] then you can
pull it off and it all works
boy million dollars I get a kind of girl
yeah yeah no she said a million she said
honey
it's not that like 10 20 you have
tattoos you can used to write it's I
don't even remember
no Jews for the longest and I was like
oh [ __ ] Bar has tattoos do you I want to
get it to to fish this big you can't
like that joke you have stories of you
[ __ ] having a fish putting in a tank
and then eating well that was a tilapia
everyone needs to La Pia but you can't
go no but nobody eats because he's mine
tilapias that's yeah eating a goldfish
that's a fish that gets eaten yeah
people said it's okay what's up with
that dude would you get that I would get
like like I don't know my wedding
anniversary or some skin but I guess not
it is we put our own names on our body
first name I always see that remember
stuff too
I remember seeing a very memory of Adams
face do I was an airport and I saw this
guy and he had it was like a really bad
picture of his friend and then you could
tell that he they cropped it and put
like a sunset behind their friend and I
said oh like in memory Alonso or
something and but it just looks so tacky
and mad like you know what like I love
you guys but I don't think I would ever
do anything like that's like except for
you you were going to face up to it yeah
alright no not his baby passed away I
get his name if Bart passed away I'd put
on the back of my car and have a big
[ __ ] deep decal it says in memory you
know birthmarks that's not big
commitment
you know I'd get it how about I get it
paint on my [ __ ] hood I get it paint
on my hood okay that's a better classic
okay yeah but I feel like if you're
gonna get a tattoo definitely spend the
money to do it right because you can
probably make the in loving memory of
whoever look really good but if you
don't spend a lot of money than you want
so do your research that's pretty good
where would you get it done on your
chest where would I get it done what
yeah where I don't know probably like
somewhere in here cuz I don't think I
can pull off that T's very well barbed
wire and a [ __ ] eagle yeah basically
I can get two things and get the
American flag are like a [ __ ] boat
and you have a farmer's tab but we're a
cut-off t-shirt yeah there you go
but imagine you like dressing the way
you usually dress which is very nice gym
shorts with it your wife has done a good
job recently is what I'm trying to say
stubbornness buck and but like imagine
you're the biggest neck tattoo that
would totally change your image no would
also choose me I would be the most
awkward [ __ ] never what if I got a
tattoo of like Selena it would say like
in memory I know some [ __ ] and then
people back I guess Selena what do you
want I really have no just want
something and I'm not even close to even
coming up with like a concept
nothing like I'm so far away from
knowing what I want I think what you
have to know is that it doesn't have to
be that deep it really you can literally
get anything tattoo I feel like that for
the first tattoo before like I need like
my family's background all on my back or
whatever you know it just literally it
does not have to be that deep you know
notice from in that tattoo people
because you always just try to ask him
what it means and I'm sure the most
annoying thing to you is because I'm
like I'm not allowed to tell you my life
story right now I'd be like oh my father
died and like you know this it just
looks good yeah [ __ ] moon that's with
me yeah yeah yeah so I mean you could
start with like a little butterfly or
like you know something like that
I think so the closest thing I have come
to right now I'm thinking about it
especially since I saw yours would be
the hanging because I had like a
childhood connection with that oh you
know and like with my dad and
and the whole like idea huyn obsessive
Chinese culture and stuff which is crazy
because I'm gonna marry a Chinese guy
but wasn't he also racist or Chinese I
thought you know let's make racist jokes
about Chinese people all the time
unintentional or intentional yeah it's
not what's like malicious intent where I
[ __ ] hate enemy we have chia-chia
hopefulness can you tell me okay tell me
an unintentional Chinese chino yeah it's
not the sock [ __ ] it's not that's just
what we it's like we like to label but
in Borneo like well the first time like
when I first got to know Gio's family so
I'm kind of like a troll like you so I
brought over like Korean barbecue so I
could make you for them in the kitchen
and when I brought it over and I served
it to people's plates and then I was
like oh how do you guys like the dog and
then her sister was like wow that's like
she actually believed me like hope you
like Goldendoodle she really thought
that I get along with my sister but
she's not that stupid cuz your brother
didn't even bother laughed and then your
sister was like no she did it it's a gay
bar like the tacos and you like thanks
it's it's chocolate lab she's an
educated person with the master's degree
all right she does not need me about
Chinese people then like you love the
culture and everything cuz it you would
have liked the Chinese medicine balls I
he used all the time he would go get
acupuncture oh love drinking the ginseng
root drink he loved monitoring your
internet and banning you from the
internet no I'm saying like that's very
recent that started to knit what he
wants she wanted to be a Chinese warlock
the internet came along is that what you
wanted to hear so he's got like
you love being cymbals so much she kept
buying me a lot of little necklaces and
always like what it's about
harmony and balance you know if you've
never explained that to me that's a part
that I'm like I don't know that [ __ ]
but now you know you know for some
reason to me he looks like a Marco like
with the Hat and then like the [ __ ]
my dad looks like Oh put in my head heat
that's what he is right and I pictured
him sitting [ __ ] Lotus tile and
meditating it [ __ ] that's funny with a
big mustache do you got the Illuminati
symbol that's tight
yeah well the all-seeing eye you know
it's funny because I follow this another
beauty blogger he means Jackie aina she
just did a cover for essence and she
cover her I like that and then people
are like oh she's in there Illuminati
gotta do it well
and she like did this whole thing where
she was like as soon as anyone has any
sort of success you guys think oh my god
you guys think that it's a thing and I
was like damn when I'm successful we're
gonna think I'm in there Lunati but
that's tight though we are part of like
a 1% so [ __ ] it maybe is that like an
application I'm in the entry I'm in the
entry level right now you I love how
everyone thinks getting into the
luminaries that easy all right
I mean I don't know I've never read into
it cuz I get really into deep into
things but I mean what is sailing money
it's a secret society they can tote
along and then they just like basically
like well you can wage war they could do
a bunch of [ __ ] they run everything yeah
it's all bad everything yeah why do
people like go oh you're everyone likes
to think that we have a free society and
[ __ ] yeah can they control everything
the idea is that there's this
underground like shadow government that
exists and they keep doing a lot of work
then yeah but hey we're firt we're gonna
be forever at war going on 21 years or
whatever the [ __ ] so yeah it's it's I
need to take people from all over the
world they all come in to is Leon saying
it of course they say beyond my friend
Madeleine Bailey she's a youtuber right
and I was I just went to her she had a
first live show in LA and I've known her
for years okay so behind her part of her
new logo there was a triangle I was like
she made it
she [ __ ] did it dude did you ask her
about it I I didn't get to because after
the show she was like swarmed by people
so I didn't get to talk to her she's my
friend so but yeah plantain or an
Illuminati show I just think it's
accessible I think it's like what you
were saying if you were like very bottom
level Illuminati or war Angelo
additional or not show people you made
it
start putting triangles on [ __ ] I know
it is impressive it's like man alright
just one triangle we should make
something else like a circle or
something it needs a brand yeah we're
like we battle them I agree
what about an upside down triangle is
that anything that's a loominatee
already it's a pizza slice
no Minotti mmm yummy pepperoni it's but
it's also that's also the Nani or
anything is it yeah anything triangle
any sort of triangle no and then I think
the thing too that people really aren't
scared about the Illuminati is because
they think it's connected to the devil
oh oh yeah that's not me what's so bad
about the devil
I can't I'm gonna be an oval like I mean
obviously there's a lot of things bad
with being the devil and [ __ ] because if
you really believe in that then that
means like you're just the source of all
evil kind of [ __ ] so that's all good
like if you sell your soul to the devil
he'll give you anything but thank you
guys your soul so he can take what
happens if anybody would have my soul on
the side either cuz I was playing a card
game in high school and then I bet my
soul and then I lost
oh [ __ ] have my [ __ ] soul that sucks
yeah you should track down that person
tell you buy your soul back I know be
like hey man I'll give you I'll give you
25 G's yeah we'll see I don't even own a
soul I read some [ __ ] that there's like
a Asian secret society thing too that's
battling out with the Illuminati because
the Illuminati only controls like I
don't know yeah but there's like it was
years ago when I read it but there's
like some kind of like battle between
them and [ __ ] oh is it a dance battle I
know they'll be dope it's kung-fu about
okay
oh that's what cane races No
that it I guess it's ok I don't know
anyway so we're glad you're back
oh thank you I was just thinking so no
hand tattoos not yet I wouldn't do it I
would get it he's hot though
sleeves is hot but no I love hand
tattoos I be honest with you no okay go
go so I I'm all about do whatever makes
you happy and I'm like yeah but and I've
looked at it and I try to look at it
like when mmm but I ever get that I just
don't like how they start getting faded
and then your hands always look dirty
but then it looks cool I like that
weathered look but okay well on a female
for me it looks dirty let me tell you
guys
so my negative side is the fact like
let's say I go into a meeting with like
people who don't know oh my god that
[ __ ] turns me on all that stuff okay but
listen and I'm like okay I gotta be
careful bla bla but think about Rihanna
to me it's the opposite but she's black
if I'm going into a meeting so you
it doesn't contrast as much like like if
you if you have lighter skin you can
really see the tattoo so it's like oh
[ __ ] just that to date yeah yeah but if
your skin's darker it kind of blends a
little bit that's true yeah that was
good as sleeved up all the time yeah see
that that's hot because I'm like [ __ ]
you're in a room now with powerful
people and you have hand tattooed and I
can afford it exactly so for me that's
when I go that's [ __ ] hot what's more
gangster in a business meeting with hand
tattoos or overstretched v-neck with
mustard stains hand tattoos one because
both are like I don't give a [ __ ] about
anything that's true that Mark
Zuckerberg show up in a robe with
[ __ ] sandals on it's the same it's
the same community with overalls with no
t-shirt and a [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
meat on your chaps
yep I just the head tattoo is a lick for
me you can always get worse it can
always get worse
yeah so I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait a
little bit what you do you try covering
your hands full yeah okay so that's what
I was thinking so I was thinking of
doing something that like just kind of
came a little bit here I also saw this
like really cool like tattoo that was
the whole hand but the whole hand kind
of scares me so I was thinking about
doing some finger
because I like finger tattoo yeah yeah
those look cute you know and they look
like rings almost um I have an idea for
you but I'll steal it okay get your foot
tattooed on that's really tight that
should actually happen for you but don't
steal it is someone else's face tattooed
on your face oh yeah why'd you give big
tattoo hell no way never because every
Mexican mom has done that and your skin
eventually sacks with age and then your
eyebrow tattoos are gonna end up down
here you want to have the flexibility to
always draw them why don't you just
start up here then oh my god and also
makeup trends change way too often for
you to tattoo something permanently on
your face yeah so that's B
[Music]